now that we've figured out the total
revenue given any given given any
quantity and we've also been able to
express it algebraically I want to think
about what the marginal revenue is at
any one of these points and to think
about marginal revenue marginal revenue
is just how much does our total revenue
change given some change in our quantity
and then later we can use that so that
the this are so that we can optimize the
profit for our monopoly over here and
I'm going to try to do it without
calculus it actually be very
straightforward to do it with calculus
because we're essentially just trying to
find the slope at any point along this
curve but I'll try to do it
algebraically and maybe it'll even give
you a little intuition for what we end
up doing eventually in calculus so the
first thing I want to do is essentially
find the slope the slope right over here
and the best way to find the slope right
over here is say well how much does my
total revenue change if I have a very
small change in quantity so if I have a
very small change in quantity how much
does my total revenue change so let me
think about it this way and the other
ones I will be able to approximate a
little bit easier so let's think of it
this way if my quantity is zero my total
revenue is zero that one's easy
if I increase my quantity very very very
very little so let's just make it zero
point zero zero one what is going to be
my total revenue and we could think
about it in terms of this curve right
over here or we could just use this
expression which we derived from price
times quantity and we will get my
calculator out if we have if our
quantity is point zero zero one our
total revenue is going to be negative
let me turn it up the calculator on
total revenue is going to be negative
point zero zero one squared squared so
that's that part plus six times point
zero zero one six times point zero zero
one so that's going to be our total
revenue so it's going to be zero point
zero zero five nine nine nine so it's
zero point zero zero five nine nine and
so now we can figure out or get a pretty
good approximation for that marginal
revenue right at that point our change
in quantity is 0.0
so our Delta Q this right over here is
0.001 that's our change in quantity and
our change in revenue is 0.005 nine nine
and so we just have to divide we just
have to flat divide point zero zero five
nine nine nine that top one our change
in total revenue divided by our change
in quantity divided by point zero zero
one and we get five point nine nine nine
nine nine it says essentially and if you
try it with even smaller numbers if you
tried this with Oh point zero zero zero
zero zero zero one you'll get you'll get
five point and you'll get even more
nines going on so the closer that you
get the smaller your change in and this
is what you essentially do in calculus
you try to find a super small change
right over here this is essentially
going to be six our marginal revenue at
this point is essentially going to be
six so what I wanted to do is I'm going
to plot marginal revenue here on our
demand curve as well around this axes
where we've already plotted our demand
curve so when our quantity is want zero
our marginal revenue if we just barely
increase quantity the incremental total
revenue we get is going to be six
so I'll just plot it I'll just plot it
right over there and that makes sense
the marginal benefit in the market is
six right at that point so if we were to
just sell a drop of orange juice or I
guess for selling oranges in this case
not juice but if we were to sell a
millionth of a pound of oranges we would
get the equivalent of roughly six
dollars per pound for that millionth of
a pound because that's the marginal
benefit for that very first incremental
chunk of orange out there in the market
so it makes complete sense now let's
think about the slope at these other
points and these I'm going to
approximate I could do it this way but
I'll just approximate it
I'll just approximate it by using other
points so if I want to find the slope
right over here what our quantity is
equal to one the slope would look like
the slope would look like that
and I'm going to approximate it by
finding the slope between these two
points I am going to approximate it
actually is going to be a very good
approximation I'll do it later with
calculus to show that it is a very good
approximation but I'm going to
approximate it by the slope between
these two points and between those two
points our change in quantity is two and
our change in total revenue is
8-hour change in total revenues eight
when we produced to our total revenue
2,000 pounds our total revenue was eight
thousand dollars so it's to it so we
have a change in total revenue of eight
or eight thousand I guess we could say
divided by a change in quantity of two
thousand so our marginal revenue at this
point is eight divided by two or eight
thousand divided by two thousand which
is four dollars per pound so when our
quantity is one our marginal revenue is
four dollars per pound is four dollars
per pound just like that now let's think
about the marginal revenue when our
quantity is two and to do that I'm going
to find the slope between these two
points we really want to find the slope
of that line but it looks like the slope
between these two points is a pretty
good approximation it's actually almost
an exact number because the way that
this is just a parabola so we can
actually do this but anyway this is
fairly straight forward once again our
change in quantity is two and our change
in total revenue our change in total
revenue is we're going from five to nine
which is four this was nine right over
here from the last video so it's four it
or you could say it's four thousand
dollars divided by two thousand pounds
gives you gives you two dollars per
pound so our marginal revenue right over
here if we have quantity of two is two
dollars per pound right at that point
for that incremental you know millionth
of an ounce that we're going to sell of
oranges we're getting the equivalent of
two dollars a pound of increased total
revenue from doing that and let's just
do one more point here and I think
you'll see why I'm only going to do one
more point if we try to go up here and
we try to figure out what is the
marginal revenue or if we essentially
say what is the slope there how much do
we get an increase in revenue if we are
if we just barely increase our quantity
and this is actually easier to look at
this is a maximum point right over here
and there in the calculus terms the
slope up there is zero we can even see
that by approximating the slope between
the slope between these two points we
have some change in quantity but we have
no change in total revenue so right at
that point right over here the slope is
barely positive right over here right at
that point the slope is zero and then
right past it it becomes barely negative
but
at that point our marginal revenue is
zero so when our quantity is 3,000
pounds our marginal revenue is zero and
then after that our marginal revenue
gets negative over here our marginal
revenue gets more and more negative but
something very interesting happens when
we plot our marginal revenue curve or
our line in this case we are getting a
line we are getting a line we are
getting a line that is twice as steep
twice as steep as our demand curve and
this is actually generalizable if we
have a linear demand curve like this it
can be defined as a line then your
marginal revenue curve for the
monopolist will also be a linear
downward sloping curve like or downward
sloping line and it will have twice the
slope so this slope over here was
negative one this slope over here is
negative two for every for every
increase in quantity the price goes down
by two increase in quantity price goes
down by two increase in quantity price
goes down by two so this is marginal
revenue and let's remind ourselves you
know we were doing all of this algebra
and all of this math here whatever what
is marginal revenue telling us this was
the demand curve it tells us for any
given price what quantity is demanded or
for any given quantity what is the
incremental marginal benefit or I guess
what's the price at which they could
sell that quantity from that we were
able to figure out the total revenue as
a function of quantity and from that
total revenue we were able to say well
look if at any of these quantities if we
were to increase a little bit more if we
were to if we were to increase quantity
a little bit more how much is our
revenue increasing and so obviously we
want to keep increasing quantity while
our revenue is well well while our the
the marginal the marginal revenue we get
is larger than our marginal cost and
I'll take that up in the next video